for all the single moms out there to be
warned da
men and their sickening ideologies these
da guys the reason why these Dow Bros um
these da guys there has been yet another
incident of a daa figure these da guys
let me share with you guys why do I have
a deep problem with the D Boys on social
media
[Music]
the main goal of a mentor is to pass on
the energy of a
[Music]
win those chosen by a mentor have the
capability to harness this energy Gilla
power for your greatest fight for all
the single ons out there to be warned
Dow
men and their sickening ideologies these
da guys the reason why these Dow Bros um
these da guys there has been yet another
incident of a daa figure these da guys
let me share with you guys why do I have
a deep problem with the da Boys on
social media yes Us St guys we're really
evil manipulative
narcissistic gaslighting we just
innately evil we pray on those are
vulnerable especially our Muslim sisters
yes that's what we do we come together
collectively and we say how can we take
advantage of the most vulnerable in our
community sisters single mothers I mean
brothers and sisters before I get into
the video of the whole situation of Z
and our dear sister I want to just talk
on about a few things I really want to
know where this phenomena is coming from
as if us da guys are just perverted
individuals who wake up in the morning
before we have breakfast we focus and
think and we have this big master plan
of taking advantage of sisters I mean
I'm just really curious like what is it
that we have done that we've got this
label I mean was I caught with
prostitutes 3 4 days ago and it was
exposed was Zaki Nik caught with a woman
was mu sending nude pcks was Muhammad
caught in the red light district what
has what have we done Ahmed the great
Giants of The Da what have we done so
much that this label off all these da
guys every single video especially from
sisters for some odat reason is these da
guys and these da boys and these da men
and this I mean just imagine for a
second I started this video and I've got
a lot of personal experiences when it
comes to single mothers from my personal
life when I was looking to get married
yes I've had majority has been very good
and there's been times where it's been
bad imagine I start a video and I go
these single mother hijabis oh more
specifically single mother hijabi
eritreans or pakistanis or bengalis or
Turkish or whatever you want to name it
why would I generate realize a big group
of people to a couple of people that had
a bad experience with why we really need
to be careful there's so much slander
being out there and it's all coming down
to like us now just because someone does
something I mean couple of months AG it
was the whole sisters cannot wear the
jacket because their shoulders short
something so ridiculous like that okay
now what's that got to do with me why
are we all in the same category
something else happens we're all labeled
so let's not generalize and fear Allah
Allah tell us in the Quran to speak the
truth even if it's yourself or your kin
or your kin brothers and sisters when I
came to Islam W I got kicked out I was
called Isis I was called a terrorist I I
I was away from my house for 3 months
okay I was kicked out okay and I was
called everything but to me when I
looked in the mirror I had to be true to
myself and say Ali am I going to turn my
back on this religion because I'm under
pressure or this that and I'm being
called names
never never I don't care if the entire
Globe came against me I know Islam is
the truth and I will stand by that insh
till the day I die I'm not going to be
seded so my loyalty in this situation
I'm going to be talking about is not
with anybody not with the sister not
with Z not with Muhammed not with not
with nobody not even
myself I swear upon the r of the ca I am
going to be just as much as I can okay
I'm not nobody's side one thing I want
to mention is I have three daughters I
have a seven-year old old I have a
three-year-old and I have a one-year-old
they are my daughters and everyone every
father knows how they are close to their
daughters they are my life and they are
a part of me I would never ever ever
even if I did not have daughters before
when I didn't I would never ever be
biased or this misconception that has
been spread about us around that we're
misogynistic we hate women I wake up and
I just look at my da go I hate you guys
I look at my wife and go I hate you the
most actually and my mom let's be just
here that's what I'm saying now coming
into this matter when we're talking
about vulnerability and single mothers
now I'm going to be very brutal and
honest in this matter and I've have done
this long time ago 9 to 10 years ago me
and Aki aan done a video about single
mothers because he was married to a
single mother I had a c show called the
reality show and the video is that you
can watch it for yourself 9 10 years ago
I was talking about this I was doing
PSAs nine 10 years ago how single
mothers are looked down upon especially
in the Asian Community I've spoken about
this in the bit of Truth show as well
how they look down upon as if they are
less worthy they have nothing to offer
they are trash they are use good I have
spoken about this 9 10 years ago so
nobody can dare to come and talk to me
about oh this that or whatever if
there's anybody that can talk about this
issue of vulnerability of single mothers
and speaking up for their right it has
been me and I don't want to cookie and a
thank you very much I don't need that
and I'm not doing this to boast I spoke
about that not only that about five six
years ago there was somebody that I knew
I don't want to get into details yes who
was doing things that was inappropriate
messaging sisters inappropriate ways
calling them to inappropriate things he
was not necessarily in the da scene
still I done a video called warning
sisters against Ali dawa why I made it
clickbait you guys know I'm I'm a PhD in
my clickbait I done that and I made a
thumbnail that made it look like I got
CAU out and some sisters exposing me
alhamd there was a lot of sister
obviously you know they're waiting for
this opportunity by we're going to talk
about those sisters as well and i' done
this video why do you think i' done this
video I done this video to warn sisters
that whoever it is that even if it's Ali
dawa coming and approaching you because
I know sisters are hypergamous by Nature
so when it comes to us we have a great
power in our hands have to be honest as
people in the public sphere da or not da
you have a great power in your hands
because when sister see you sadly they
have this attitude of oh my gosh Ali da
oh my gosh it's this person they have
this sadly we have this power and we
need to be responsible with it that's
why I done that video to tell sisters my
dear sisters if it is me messaging you
whoever it is if you see us cross the
line you put it on us and you warn us
and if you see us carrying on you go
public and expose us if we are calling
you to Haram if we are talking to in
appropriate way because it is not
permissible outright I done that video
it was against you myself and all the
public figures and it was a message to
that brother who was acting up may Allah
forgive him he's repented changed his
ways no problem but the point is what it
was a warning so and we spoke about this
on the bit of Truth as well Single
mother's being looked down upon divorce
is being looked down upon we talk about
how they play the role of a mother and a
father and they should be looked after
and I've emphasized this so many times
that's my point now when it comes to my
personal experience and I'm going to go
to the Jose isue in a minute our brother
and our dear sister I personally when I
was looking to get married I met
multiple single mothers for marriage and
I was not married already I was looking
to get married as my first wife
and I was looking to get married and I
would make meet single mothers who had
two kids a child yes some of them
divorce uh divorce sisters I had no
issue with a sister to me personally it
was like maximum two kids it's personal
preference for me and I said the sister
with two kids I have no problem and
believe me when I went to these marriage
meetings and I would meet them I saw
vulnerability how number one cuz I'm a
public figure obviously when they see me
oh my gosh they see me on TV or YouTube
oh my gosh Ali dawa you know he's he's
he chose like he he wants to marry me
like w there was one sister Allah is my
witness
she made it seem as if I was doing her a
favor and I had to reiterate and repeat
and say my dear sister look I'm not here
to do you a favor I'm not I don't want
you to feel I don't know how certain
Community have made you feel I'm not
here to make you feel as if I'm doing
you a favor because I am choosing to
marry you and you've got kids I'm not
doing that I'm not here to do that okay
I made that clear but I noticed this
vulnerable situation single mothers were
in and I'm not seeing all of them are
Angel by the ways I've had quite a few
one or two majority was good one or two
bad experiences but the point is what
the vulnerability is there now as men we
have a responsibility to know better
Brothers I know of stories I know of
stories and a sister came to me three
four months ago where she was married to
somebody and he married her and then
after that he just chucked her away like
this she spoke to me I spoke to in
person you know I said to her I said go
expose him she didn't tell me who it was
I said I don't get who it is I don't
even want to know I don't want to know
go expose him go expose him why did I
say say no no sh sister don't tell
anybody sh no no no did he do that to
you yes I've heard your side I don't
know who he is ask for his side if he
did that to you truly and he's made you
feel like this go public not only that I
even said to her let's do a video I will
interview you go public why is my
loyalty with da da guys this no I don't
give a damn I don't who you are my Lo is
Allah and his messenger so that is there
we as men need to know better so and I'm
was saying by the way I know some
stories of brothers who have married
single mothers and single these single
mothers have lied and it's G parship so
be s brothers don't look at single
mothers as like oh they are absolutely
innocent no no no be careful be wary
single mothers be wary of Brothers
brothers be let they be that thing there
no problem we have to be cautious we
have to tie your camel so the point I'm
seeing is there is vulnerability on that
side and one thing that I would say
which I do not agree with sister soul
I'm going to mention it yep sister soul
you're watching this probably may Allah
bless and preserve you one thing she
would always say the bit the truth show
is
what um healing accountability I would
just love it when sister so would say
accountability and S uh healing may
Allah bless her with a uh Algerian
French accent accountability and healing
accountability and healing if my dear
sistant if you guys do not go to through
the process of healing and
accountability um and cuz you need to
you wasn't like this whole phenomena as
well of your ex-husbands are all
narcissists and manipul all of them
Subhan Allah when I speak to majority of
single mothers who come to me for some
odat reason all of their ex-husbands are
like that sometimes there has to be
accountability there has to be healing
once you do the healing then you can get
out the zone of thinking oh my gosh I'm
less worthy no you're not you're a
Muslim woman Allah subh has honored you
Allah has honored you and you should not
settle but you should also be realistic
on your expectations as well this goes
both ways now coming to this issue
brother zade's situation and our the
sister may Allah subhana bless and
preserve them both may Allah protect and
preserve them honor both of them it is
the duty of a Muslim to defend honor or
what it is and if they are wrong is to
call them to account and this is what we
do if somebody crosses the boundaries of
the Shar we will call them out and if
they don't we will defend them to the
death of us I don't care who it is
Sister single mother brother I don't
care who is we will defend the honor in
this situation I heard these stories
things going on EX I don't know what was
going on I didn't know what was going on
okay I heard this this happened that
happened at one moment I started to
think Subhan Allah
like something really bad happened like
really really bad like I thought like
man just Z was he calling the sister to
hotels was he I just didn't know what
was going on because the situation was
cuz like I was just seeing this video
here this these single these da guys I I
was like what came out I don't know what
came out and after I watched the
sister's video I said bro I'll be honest
with you I don't blame the sister at all
for her to feel to her to feel how she F
felt I don't blame her like the words
the choice of words you used the way you
came across bro I understand look I'm a
man I've been in this situation bro it
was Peak when I was new to Islam and I
was not married for 3 years coming from
a Jah looking to get married and it's
difficult to get married it was Peak it
was Peak bro believe me I've been where
you at I understand I hear you but bro
the way you approached it the way you
made her feel yes was wrong and she
deserves an apology and brother Zade
will do that apology in inshah however
there is context now we need to C things
in context because I was under the
assumption
that brother Zade proposed to her now
let's listen to The Voice Notes cuz I
listened to it a couple of times and I
noticed a specific pattern now let's
just listen to it ourselves in so
obviously this is an between not and
Allah just a a query which is long story
short due to my situation um I'm not
married yet by the way I've never been
married however as you can understand as
a man this is very difficult um
especially in you know time of F that I
live in ume considering my social media
and you know of that um and obviously
coming from a cultural family as do a
lot of people uh you know the typical
traditional marriage is very difficult
sometimes to find that that person you
know get together there a you know well
blah blah blah it's you know the woman's
first time getting married same for the
man you know traditional marriage from
two essentially virgins um but my my
question is and query is I was thinking
that uh since I'm struggling to find the
uh woman or a woman for marriage uh as a
sort of first wife that I would call a
traditional wife that my family meets
and they go over houses and then there's
in-laws and all this typical stuff I was
thinking in the meantime until I find
that because it's quite difficult to
find what I'm looking for what my family
would be happy with I was thinking to
just marry someone else in the meantime
and the option I was thinking of was
someone like a single mother uh for the
following reasons one is that you know
she's been married before she already
has children so her expectations uh of
her husband might not necessarily be as
much as a virgin woman and two I think
she would probably understand my
situation and you know what I'm looking
for does that make sense and would
probably be supportive of it perhaps or
cooperative in it um and she probably
wouldn't be as interested as you know a
virgin girl in getting to know the
family and in-laws and all this stuff
cuz she's already been through it you
know she's got a kid and she's just
raising the kid and she just wants a man
there who you know she can spend some
quality time with every now and then who
can you know they can protect each other
love each other and protect each other
from Zena mainly and look after each
essentially marrying a woman um and
basically not telling your family about
it obviously as a man I'm allowed to do
this this is fine I'm My Own M I'm My
Own man um but my my simple question was
as a single mother yourself in your
humble opinion and experience do you
think this is a wise idea or or you know
to to to marry basically for me to marry
like someone like a single mother just
so I can have someone there protect
myself uh have the affection and love
that every man needs until I not not not
with the intentional divorce of course
not but like as someone there until I
find that traditional quote unquote wife
that you know my family would know and
all these things uh whereas the family
wouldn't know of this other sort of
single mother wife so what do you think
as someone who's raising a you know
beautiful child as yourself is this
something that's you know how would you
feel as a as a single mother about that
I'm not talking about you specifically I
mean just single mothers in general if a
man um came with this idea to you what
would you think would you be cooperative
would you be like no of course not would
you understand his situation would you
tell him no just you know be patient
even more and go find that first wife
traditional wife blah blah blah or you
know what what do you think what would
you advice um just bearing in mind that
I'm a man I'm in 27 now obviously as you
understand a man is it's much more
difficult for a man to maintain you know
and to control themselves from that
aspect physiologically you know 20 times
more than a woman so you know very
difficult at the moment so please let me
know in may Allah bless you and this is
an a between us so now guys if you've
heard it he's talking on the third
person do you think he's basically when
I listen to I was like hold on a second
you didn't propose to her I said then
where is this rumor going around as if
you proposed to her he's like well no I
didn't this is what happened a sister
after Zade done Hajj a sister who's a
single mother proposed to Zade for
marriage and he was considering this and
I'll have the receipt in front of you
there you guys okay all right and I'm
just giving context by the way before
guys oh here we go he's defending I'm
not defending no one I'm bringing
context cuz there are people accusing Z
of calling her to m in a
marriage let's be just let's be just
here what he did and how he done it was
wrong and he should apologize for making
that sister feel like that however Zade
has approached this sister I don't know
s sister's name may Allah bless and
preserve her and he's asking her for a
and he's saying this is an A so he's
come to her which is the most naive
awkwardly naive thing I've ever seen in
my life I thought I was so awkwardly
naive bro and then he's messaging her
and saying I am planning on you know the
thing traditional wife children Etc but
one thing you notice he does not say I
want to I want to marry this sister not
her he's asking for n on behalf of what
he the other sister proposed to him so
he's saying do you think it's the right
thing to do so now the sister has a
right to be offended in the message and
tell him brother and give him the put
him in his place stick it on him no
problem this the brother has come to you
my dear sister which I believe this is a
mistake you made as it was an am now you
broke that am no problem I'm not going
to come and say to you it was wrong
however my dear sister he's come to you
asking you and I know you feel offended
on behalf of other sisters of single
mothers because of his conditions or
whatever for that matter yeah but he
does not say he wants to temporarily
marry he's saying he wants to find the
second wife first which is going to be
his first wife then become his second
wife okay and then he's going to stay
married to her Etc okay now looking at
this this is called M marriage what is M
marriage M marriage is at the discretion
of the woman so the woman has the right
to say I forgo my rights I choose to she
can say by Night financially whatever
it's at her discretion she can let go of
her rights now this is not for every
sister and sister can feel offended
that's fine and good but a sister who
doesn't mind being in that situation for
the sister who proposed to him Etc you
cannot blame her and make her feel like
she is you know not getting her Worth or
whatever that matter it is between two
adults if they want to do that that's at
their discretion but if we're looking at
the thing there was nothing Haram done
please bring me evidence from the Quran
Sunnah if the proposal was Haram was it
offensive yes was it made to seem like
she's less worthy yes but the am was
there and I want to put you guys and put
yourself in the situation if a sister
messaged me as a married man and said
Brother Ali there is for example asking
for I want to ask you please a Mana
between us and you no problem sister
what's a question there is a brother I'm
in a financial difficult situation I've
got two kids and I don't really like him
it's not my liking but I feel Zen for
myself and financially he's a rich guy I
don't you know financially I'm in a good
place I want to marry him now in this
situation you would see that he is she's
basically kind of taking opportunity of
him he's kind of in a vulnerable
situation ation he she wants to marry
him now I would personally say my dear
sister if you don't have attraction to
him if you don't like him like that I
wouldn't advise you to do that however I
will feel offended I'll be like you know
what I mean the fact that you want to
marry him for his you know money and you
know you want to protect yourself from
zner okay it's an honorable thing I
understand I would be a bit tasteful now
imagine if I broke the am and I went
public I just want you guys to
understand I'm not blaming the sister
but just put yourself in the shoe if I
went to public and I exposed and smash
and I said this sister just messag me
I'm warning everyone against these kind
of sisters who are using men as a cash
machine gold diggers d da da da da what
would you sisters say would you sisters
not come to me and say oh my gosh she
messaged you privately it was an am yes
maybe what she done was wrong wanting to
marry the guy for goldan or whatever
protect from Z whatever that's not
necessarily wrong but you didn't have to
go public why are you putting her on
blast for she was in a vulnerable state
you will do everything in your power to
defend that sister yes and I would say
you know what that's valid now how has
Zade become a predator I really want to
understand he's coming there naively and
telling you the blueprint of what he
thinks is good to do and he's coming to
you as a single mother out of everybody
for that matter cuz you're single mother
going more offended and he's telling you
should I do this my dear sister all you
had to do is tell him and put him in his
place and say what you're doing is wrong
you shouldn't do it single mothers give
him the and pack him and do a general
video and if you did a video without
mentioning his name I'm fully I would
have shared that video no problem
because I know there are men out there
who take advantage of vulnerable sisters
I do but the point is what the point is
that people are now turned this into a
mut marriage Zena is this he should be
warn da guys all of
them this is disgusting don't generalize
everyone do not generalize everyone my
matter in this is that brother Zade
should apologize for making the sister
feel in that way less worthy that you
know whatever it's for that matter no
problem the sister felt offended no
problem however M marriage is totally
totally valid and it is at the
discretion of a woman and let me tell
you my dear sisters a hint why men men
are going down this route of having
secret second wives which we've done a
whole show about and people think I just
done it for the sake of it because of
their first wives blunt to the point and
I've said this before because of the
pressure of the first wife because we as
men are polygamous by Nature I do not
care how much you hate that I do not
care how much you're going to attack me
I will speak the truth I do not need
your thank you I do not need your
applause I don't I don't care about you
talking bad about I don't care as long
as it's the H men Muslim are polygamous
by nature and I know so many so many who
have are getting secret second wives why
because their first wife will destroy
and let me tell you something in most
scenarios does the first wife come and
say this is a single mother vulnerable
look after her no it is those wom single
the first wives who are saying I don't
care to hell with her hope she dies that
W they destroy these marriages you know
who it is it is the First Wives
destroying it even if they marry
somebody who's not a single mother even
if Brothers wanted to do something good
and let me be honest with you and I tell
this to the brothers do not oppress a
single mother or any woman because you
fear your first wife do not give them
their rights give them their Jew rights
look after them you have to marry them
even if it's missad you've seen them
you've agreed to two days three days
whatever for that matter you have to
love them you have to treat them they
like your wife not like some side chick
Islam has come to protect polygam has
come to defend the right of the woman
you look after her you cherish her you
take care of her you treat your their
kids as much as like your kids to the
best your ability I'm not saying you
must love them like their own father
loves them no but do not at the cost of
your first wife fear you fearing your
first wife that you now oppress and my
dear sisters I've said this before and
I'll finish on this note ask for a
decent Mah and have a proper Guardian
that cares about you not some next waste
man who's just going to be there like
yeah go get no have a proper guardian
and ask for a DEC Mah these are the two
things that will protect you against men
who are praying on vulnerable women and
my Brothers do not look at every woman
single mother not and see as if they are
just you know misin trust me I know some
horror stories so be careful yourselves
as well I'm not going to make this about
oh old sisters are vulnerable no they
are not oh believe me they are not and
that's all I want to say anything I said
bad is from Shayan and myself anything
good is from Allah subhana wa tala hope
this has clarified it and Zade in will
come out with an apology which he
rightly should do so and I will leave
this matter hopefully I haven't forgot
about anything except alul